as copic cases climb and vaccine rates
level off some fear the virus may never
fully go away typically the case with a
virus but what exactly does a future
with kobit look like
will it be like the seasonal flu
something even more dangerous
or go mana jonas live with what we can
possibly
expect in the long term orca
well brian the expert i spoke with
tonight says the biggest concerns right
now
are with vaccine hesitancy and
misinformation and if not enough people
get the vaccine
coven 19 will continue to transform and
get stronger
some people are already preparing for
that potential future
the degree of hesitation we're seeing
with this fatal disease
is quite frankly surprising as coveted
vaccination rates lag in nevada and the
delta variant takes hold it's clear
we're not out of the woods yet
dr mark j khan says our current
situation is unprecedented
in the past with other vaccines like for
smallpox and
polio we didn't have this type of
misinformation that we're seeing now
if things do not change dr khan says
kovit will be around for a while and
that booster shots are likely
but it's unclear if it'll become like
the flu or something
worse i do worry that if we don't get
people vaccinated we're going to
continue to have mutations
that are going to be more transmissible
we had to really make some investments
pastor kelsey west with nehemiah
ministries tells me he's prepared for
life with kovit for the foreseeable
future he still plans to cap his
congregation at 100 people
enforce social distancing and mandate
masks we haven't had a reason
to really think that covet is going to
totally disappear
others do not believe the virus will be
a long-term problem
i think realistically unless it starts
to impact
our youth children 12 and under i don't
think we need to panic while the future
is
uncertain medical experts agree on one
thing only through vaccination
are we going to get to the other side of
this pandemic
now dr khan also says in order to combat
vaccine hesitancy
and misinformation it's important to get
your information from reputable sources
like the southern nevada health district
and local hospitals and also you should
not always rely on what you see
on social media reporting live in las
vegas tonight orca mana 8 news now